this girl is a monster that's white girl
summer all over the monster son white
girl summer is back in full swing
unhatable
ow let me get some volume please um the
expectation the bar so long no no no no
no no no no no no you just gotta be able
to wrap up
and they both know it low-key
[Music]
can you wrap this verse hell
what I mean words what song is this
[Music]
obvious everybody knows it
[Laughter]
what is the name of the song is wants
and knees by by Drake little baby yeah
nobody know that [__] yeah yeah we don't
know you just saved a little baby song
like that's it there's little baby stole
the song yeah that is true and like
that's this yeah you're aware of the
song and the little baby stole it but
you know any of the words no no I know
something what is it I know some of the
word
son this guy I don't know a single
[__] word she's fine but give her her
credit
let's shorty Rocks body bags bro she did
it
yeah
let's play that game oh no
my [__] gonna go harder all right
you don't know a single word to yourself
foreign
[Music]
you're a [__] Boomer
that's a boomer brother thank you but
what song do you know front to back yo
any song
any song that you know I know about it
all right pick a Jay-Z song Renegade
Jay-Z and Eminem all right let's go
let's go sing it
hey yo
um
if it's Jay-Z I know it how do you not
know the words of that song you could do
Jay-Z
you could do Jesus
you do Red Hot Chili Peppers
let's go out you get to pick a black
song I pick a white song and then we go
bar for [__] bar oh [__] you're
not ready for this bro pick a song uh
put on Renegade
all right you gotta do Eminem's first
I'll do Jay-Z oh [__] he got you that's
easy
bro I hope I got this [__] this is easy
now we got it
what the [__]
that's what you mean
all right guys we're gonna take a break
for a second because thousands of
companies are collecting aggregating and
trading your personal data without you
knowing anything about it and you have
the right to request data Brokers to
delete what information they have about
you and protect your privacy the bad
news is it would take you years to do it
manually Incognito can do the messy work
for you automatically incogni helps you
protect your privacy and take your
personal data off the market by reaching
out to the data Brokers on your behalf
requesting your personal data removal
and dealing with their objections okay
what data companies hold most often they
got your full name email home address
that's [__] terrifying shopping
habits your social security number and
more okay it is crazy so this is
something that you need to know okay if
you subscribed for a free newsletter
shortly after you start receiving lots
of spam from unknown senders yep that's
it you could have got hot okay simple as
that someone that you don't know found
out your home address phone number and
personal information about your
relatives even so what we're going to do
right now is for the first 100 people to
use the code Schultz that's Schulz at
the link below
they're going to get 20 off of incogni
protect your privacy today go to
incogni.com
Schultz use the code Schultz to take
your personal data off the market now
let's get back to the show
but you gotta memorize the whole [__]
also the intro sounds way different ways
hold on we got this let's go
let's go say that I'm stupid y'all only
talk about Jews do you fools listen to
music or do you just skip through it see
I'm influenced by the ghetto you ruined
the same dude that made something I made
something doing what I do doing soon I
give you the news with a two [__] just
his ghetto point of view you Renegade
you've been afraid I penetrate pop
culture put them a lot closer to the
block where they pop toasters and they
live with their mom got dropped roasters
[Music]
I do a white chocolate oh you don't want
me to do uh
I run it back a little bit
this one right here yeah he's like
Eminem's in this one
he says my name is
in America
[Music]
okay
cool
[Music]
I gotta leave foreign
I could probably do a good amount of uh
Dreams and Nightmares without the
n-words
you're not with the n-word so if you're
gonna do what you gotta do it
you can say sand before if you say sand
before you're fine
yeah are you ready all right here we go
hit it the fans are you looking to love
or hate this episode
you ready yo you ready
ah
[Music]
I used to drink for times like this to
grind like this so I had to run like
that to shine like this in a matter of
time I spent or some locked up [__] in
the back of the Paddy Wagon cups locked
on wrist see my dreams come true
Nightmares come true it was time to
marry the game and I said yeah I do got
shorty I see it with a clear eye view
got short she trying to bless me like I
said I chew like a [__] squeeze [__]
please for them squeeze I'm getting
cream never let the hoes get in between
what we started little but I'm lying
hard if they love it when I was healing
they hated when I departed I go and get
it regardless like I'm an artist foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought I was finished
foreign
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this Unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's the top 10
patreon in the [__] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com
flagrant2 alright peace